j'aime beaucoup ce [ __ ] on boit une
gorgée une gorgée seulement tfc dès que
dacia fait confiance au coach thomas à
[Musique]
c'est le beer pong wayne fait c'est le
pire pont de pierre pons on est là en
face de l'autre 3 2 balles de ping pong
ouais on lance la balle ouais si on la
met dans le gobelet fort rebond il faut
un rebond là et un rebond life audio
possible si ça tombe dans le gobelet
l'adversaire d'en face est éliminé et
surtout il boit mais cette chose mais
c'est quoi ces regards croisés
dégueulasse non non non c'est
passablement dénoncé ces deux drames il
dit dans bams annoncé comestibles mais
ce n est pas cela très beau diable et
bientôt car pas possible allez jamais
joué ou quoi alors on pas loin je
signais lalala et les latins de gala la
table est pas droite
là on me dit vous devez voir sattouf
merci bonsoir on s'arrête on allait à
tournon servent ensuite à petit elle le
voit vraiment aller c'est bien sûr
vigueur au deuxième partie à faire ce
qu'on appelle du close up close up c'est
la magie très large chérèque en connaît
le crosa vous connaissez très bien
record où cela aurait besoin d'un jeu de
cartes venez on va se rapprocher la
caméra nous sommes allés les cartes top
toute différente on est d'accord alors
benjamin vous le placez votre doux à
l'intérieur est même sélectionné in cape
bravo hasard attention allez-y go c'est
très bon sur le doigt boudoir hop vous
regardez la carte vous la montre à tout
le monde sauf à moi et vous l'imprimé
dans votre esprit en retourne
il est à fond max ouais ok ou la place
et il s'attend à cornes dont il a pris
la confiance ce congrès voilà vous ici
d'accord ok très bien roulé ce qui se
passe bien posée à l'intérieur mais
prend la première carte points derrière
c'est ma carte c'est le 2 2 carreaux
très bien le 2/4 aux japonais reste le
deux caveaux passe ici est votre carte
pass juste là on n en a pas des heures
les plus concentrées elles cassent avait
toujours la plus angoissante et flury
blessé anthony lorsque pas engorger une
gorgée seulement des gaves c'est
dégueulasse ya c'est comme le scotch ou
et non alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait
sept soldats olalala l'humanité
attention je gagne à la sirène est bien
là perdu à l'intérieur c'est juste ça
elle remonte sur le dessus alors
mentionné sur le but du jeu c'est les
faire disparaître et c'est plus
compliqué ces deux messieurs bien on
fait 1 2 3 mais la carte va me
véritablement disparaître de prb dessus
la carte est disparue la personne ne
croit bien évidemment non
regardez et la caf vraiment s'est
dissipée c'est pourquoi non parce que si
je fais ça ouvrez ouvrez votre pochard
est allé de danse elle est dedans ça
devrait aller de danger de fermeture
mais après tout doucement la caméra le
montre bien le gardien d'une seule
bernard way
[Applaudissements]
et là on a beau chez vous regardez bien
un deux trois toutes les cartes se
transforme voilà
or là
bref au maxi maxi maxime j'ai un conseil
arrêtez les médias oif et trop fan mais
vous êtes lario meilleures en asie dans
média avec isabelle jeu peut durer des
heures et j'étais pas loin
ouais mais il faut pas être pas loin il
faut être dedans ouais c'est ça ouais la
presse comme avec alain attendrait
toujours raison attention vérifiez après
que vous rejoins jeannois c'est quoi ce
que ce soit les salles est à vomir ces
dernières allaient assez dégueu la main
ensuite si je remporte cette partie vous
gagnez l'imprimante portable
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]